you play a very sexually open character
yes I mean my character actually like
beat off at work in the first season I
don't know where we go from there
your ass I don't know where we go from
from there either
I think we're done everybody description
on the TV guy beats off at work yeah
first of all just thanks for throwing
that out there
second of all I didn't think women refer
to it that way well I read little
digital self diddle a little self-love I
mean I don't know I guess every gal has
her own way of referring to it or just a
little alone time I don't know time is
fine alone I think let's agree on alone
time those other ones are I mean yeah
the other one the first one you started
with sounded like that's what guys say I
don't know I mean I could be wrong I
don't know what do I know I don't get
out a lot I think like masturbate sounds
so clinical and not not it definitely
sound that fun but it is we knew exactly
what you
yeah yeah alone time could be any right
exactly yeah a long time you can be you
know ordering pizza or calling the Cable
Guy right a long time we're friends I
ease yeah okay beat off you know what's
going down it's a great time with
yourself
oh god okay
you